so much for civility in America First
Lady Melania Trump met with a chorus of
boos and some cheers as she spoke about
the nation's opioid crisis during a
youth summit in Baltimore the first lady
responding with a statement quote we
live in a democracy and everyone is
entitled to their opinion but the fact
is we have a serious crisis in our
country and I remain committed to
educating children on the dangers and
deadly consequences of drug abuse one I
wanted to ask you you know at the time
on stage I thought she was so graceful
and that she said you know we're fight
you're fighting with me but I'm fighting
for you how do you think how do you
think as someone who has a lot of
disagreements with this administration
that her that that that that look is how
do you feel about her statement look you
may be fighting with me but I am still
fighting for you in what is a larger
issue at stake here I think was graceful
I think she should have said that and I
think it that's the way to handle I
don't think that she was gonna fire back
remember we're talking about mostly kids
it wasn't adults but the second thing to
say is wow she had to know she was going
into the lines then because her husband
had just absolutely demolished Baltimore
and said the most horrible things you
know this is no human being would want
to live here rat infested dangerous but
about you know and Baltimore has its
deficits there's no getting away from it
but once you go into somebody's house
after telling them you know that they're
unworthy and denigrate you know I just I
dropped it and demolished Baltimore he
did well no no but if you speak about
people that way even if people someone
sick or someone has problems it doesn't
help them and of course the kids are
gonna respond on a visceral level which
is to say that may have heard it from
the appearance but the way a child
reacts is to say you're a bad guy and
you know so I was actually I thought she
handled it with some grace as I said but
I don't I think she had to know what was
going on when she stepped in the
Baltimore
Lawrence you spend so much time on
campuses what are your thoughts on that
and is it a smaller fraction of the
population than people on the coast make
it seem well you know I
think there is a bit conversation that
we got to have about the outre culture
and just general respect but I applaud
the first lady for staying on message
because she didn't want to make it about
her I think the president if I have one
critique of him he can learn that from
Melania is that sometimes you don't have
to swing back sometimes you can stay on
their message and I think more people
would support him as a result of this
but the follow up on want one support
part about Baltimore I think that's
wrong I've been to Baltimore I actually
talked to the resident of Baltimore
they're more concerned about the
corruption in Baltimore and you have the
first lady going in there to highlight
some issues that are going in a graceful
way and the kids who should have been
taught respect because there are many
policies that disagree with
I never booed them because I want to
hear their perspective they're not being
taught then I think that's a problem
Dana do you think if Trump wins the next
election that there will be ever a
separation between him and Melania will
will there be parts of America that ever
support her rather than attributing or
ascribing the negative things that they
feel he does to her
oh well I think that she has shown just
incredible grace and dignity and
integrity she in which is not her first
language so getting up in front of
America to speak all the time especially
if you know you're going to a place
where you might be booed now one of the
things that's happening this month or
this quarter is that President Trump is
donating his press salary to the opioid
crisis and they have fought for a lot of
money she has traveled this country she
actually really cares so I hate to see
anybody booed I'm not I just
I would not participate in that and as
to the future I do think that going
forward um because she's made a real
mark with her be best campaign focusing
on children especially on opioids but
for a second term there is opportunity
for her to take on something more I
would love to see the first lady tried
to address the foster care system in our
country and adoption to that this month
November is National Adoption Month and
her her joy that she obviously has when
she talks about children and when she's
around children is persuadable and
persuasive excuse me and I think that
she will
have something that is separate from him
I don't think they the two of them are
not going to be separated right in the
nation's eyes yeah Greg your thoughts in
the era in the era of Trump any linkage
to him from marriage to blood to wearing
a hat to not actually actively joining
the resistance it incriminates you right
so it's wherever you go and you know
obviously if this happened without
saying but I'm gonna say if it's
happened to Michelle
the media would torch the school they
would go crazy but the rule is in my
life never talk to a large group of kids
right they would boo their own parents
they would heckle the Pope so guy to
your point give her credit I mean
imagine if you move to it like an
Eastern European country because your
spouse became president and then you had
to go speak to a group of brats and you
have a convenient in Slovenian and your
act your English accents hilarious she's
not just she's she's not just graceful
she's brave yeah you know but and
meanwhile people are advocating for
lowering the voting age - people have
got volatile adolescence imagine they
might be impulsive you know Emily they
might they might be at a rally in
Florida and use be s in front of
children
kids are gonna be kids there's a
disrespectful population I'm sure they
all went home and had a good talking-to
from their parents I hope so
that's why we have to keep it in school
all day into the night